House Republicans have proposed a
blueprint for tax reform, under which the
United States would adopt a system of
destination-based cash flow taxation at
the corporate level. What does it mean
for corporate taxation to be destination-based,
as opposed to origin-based? It means
that it's the location of the consumer,
not of the producer, that determines
where the cash flow from a transaction
is taxed. But the locations of consumer and
producer often of the same. Herein lies
the complication if consumption taxation
takes place at the corporate level, as it
would under the House plan and under
value-added tax systems. One has to then exempt the
cash flow from sales to consumers abroad,
and tax the imports purchased by the
domestic consumers from overseas
producers. Now as long as the US runs a
trade deficit, the revenue from taxing
imports exceeds the revenue loss from
not taxing exports, and House Republicans
like that, because it lets them reduce taxes elsewhere.
And that, in a nutshell, is
what border adjustment is.
To learn more about my take on border adjustment,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you
want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.